The thing we should do with people who
create art that have done terrible
things as well.
If you found out as I head of Johnson
and Johnson was a serial rapist that
everybody at Johnson and Johnson knew
one way or another,
would you still buy that baby powder?
Sorry.
Your heroes are going away.
Why aren't there more important things
to do?
Okay.
Sorry.
Bummer.
For you.
Within the construct of society,
the raping and killing of women,
there's a channel called Id.
It's devoted to 24 hours a day of
sexualizing murder victims.
Okay.
Stop it.
That's my message is knock it off when
you don't get to like woody Allen.
Oh,
what a big,
huge loss for you.
I'm sure that compares to the girl who's
just been raped.
That now feels like she wants to hang
herself from her balcony.
Right?
Cause that really balances out.
So when people bitch about that.
Sorry,
bomber for you,
you don't watch birth of a nation to
you?
Probably not because you know it's
racist.
So in time these people will be looked
at like that.
My job and other jobs at work in kind of
what I'm doing is to put an asterisks
next to these assholes names for all
time and if people want to cry about not
getting into like somebody they liked on
their kids
will get a fucking bigger problem.
It's not that complicated.
People really not.
It's really not.
It's easy.
Read a different book.
I,
I have so many people fighting me
because they want to stay in the system.
The system benefits a point.
Zero,
zero,
one percent.
My ultimate goal is smashing the 99 in
the one percent.
That's what I'm here for.
I'm here to do that through thought and
raising women up and yes,
in in children of God,
the cult I was born into and again it
seems like,
oh,
they make a big deal of the cult.
My.
I would be talking about Ohio if that
happened to be my life.
That just was not,
but that's a cult too and I think you
all know it.
That's the thing.
You're like,
oh,
it's so weird how you grew up.
I think it's weird how you live and I
think it's tragic because by 10 percent
because there's a lot of free minds,
they're out there for sure,
but we have to be vigilant.
What if those 10 percent of the world
that you look at as the Weirdos in the
fringe people,
what if it's you guys,
you know,
like,
just like how African Americans have
been saying.
I remember hearing about it,
reading about it when I was 13,
you know,
that they get killed when they get
pulled over by cops and that would be
like a saint maybe because someone said
that to me in Germany recently.
I said this is like kind of what a woman
experiences.
And he said maybe waving his hand.
I thought we have like a trillion,
a trillion phds in me,
a woman.
Why?
Because we're in our skin and you know
what's sad is because when you get sold
as an idea,
the other side thinks that's what you
are.
So they were.
Everybody's responding to us primarily
as an idea that's sold stamps or
imagery.
You Know Adam Sandler movies where you
have sell my at Jessica Biel,
uh,
Kate Beckinsale,
these accomplished women with Adam
Sandler are Slovenly slog who shtick is
wearing dirty pants and,
and basically having a two point two Iq,
but the message they send out as you
deserve this and that directly with all
those young boys watching leads to the
idea of undeserved there.
No,
you actually deserve a complex women,
but only if you two can match that.
During World War II,
each studio had served their rank.
They served in the military.
Their rank was ministers of propaganda
and they came to them after the war and
they said,
holy crap,
women are out in the kitchen.
Why get back in?
And that's when we started seeing Doris
Day like overdrive vacuuming every ease.
Once we put video with sound images with
sound really taken a fast.
If you notice how fast the destruction
of the world is gone,
I know tying things together,
people are like,
oh,
it can't be,
can't be responsible for all of that.
Actually,
Karen,
it really,
really can.
There's that two year old on facebook.
That video that went around,
he's punching along with rocky
and everyone's like,
isn't that cute?
No little timmy.
There's just been stolen.
You've just stolen what he is and when
you're talking about also you're telling
them what a man is.
Just especially telling them what a
white man is and especially you're
telling them how to feel.
Why are sports so popular?
They're stupid country in.
Why?
Because here,
that's how men are.
The only time traditionally they're
allowed to have an expression of energy
or a release of energy.
Fortunately it's an anger and
aggression,
but I,
I.
it's a real western societal interest,
so real American problem.
I'm worse than any other place I've
been.
I've been a lot of places and I think
when you come from a land more time
behind it,
right?
America keeps going.
We're so young.
No or not white people are yelling to
it.
You had dummies.
Greg's not young.
You just renamed it.
You know what they did in the twenties.
I thought this was the height of a
American Hubris that gave native
American citizenship if Indians
citizenship and call them names.
You know what I mean?
Like that's the mentality we're dealing
with and they fight it on every level
they fight.
I don't want the Redskins logo off this.
I won't shut up.
Shut up.
Wham.
Your sports team is sad now.
You know,
the traditional shaming thing,
what have we done since Hester Brian
come on and like,
since you know,
I don't know,
someone called Mary in the Bible.
It did the same thing to me that they
did to marry every interview is what a
man should it.
So I understood that detail,
the funneling and the system of how we
sell ideas to people,
but you have to understand it's not just
the immediate,
it was like how my family treated me
based on coverage because they're
wrestling with.
They kind of know me,
but they think they know any more from
what they see in the media because
that's what they say.
Same with any man or woman that I've
ever been with.
Anything.
Friends,
every.
It affected everything it was,
but the prison wasn't mine.
I,
you know,
that's the whole thing.
Unless you're actually behind bars,
those bars aren't there,
but we think they are as a.
You know,
I was on Stephen Colbert last night and
he said,
we were talking about I was wearing a
hoodie and he said,
oh,
I wish I could wear that hat to wear the
suit,
because I was saying I hate suits.
I feel like whenever I wear them.
And I was thinking maybe men are cranky
because of this,
because you're like a t rex.
You're hands are like,
you can't move.
It's not fun.
Right?
It's uncomfortable and men don't like to
be uncomfortable.
They don't like itchy things.
Understandably so.
That suit paradigms stupid.
And I said,
well,
what would happen to you if you didn't
wear a suit?
And he's like,
I have to wear a suit just for as long
as that.
But why?
And he actually said at the end,
we were talking about it after,
you know,
when the camera cut and like kind of
wonder why do I have to wear a suit?
Who says,
who made that rule?
Who Cares?
They also made the rule that it was
indiscriminate and okay to rape and
sexually assault in Hollywood.
It's also time to stop that and the
world.
That's a run on sentence.